welcome back everybody or for those of
you who are just able to join us this
evening welcome to the opening day of
the inaugural CMU K&L gates conference
on ethics and AI I'm David Danks one of
the co-organizers along with the Lenoir
Bosch of the conference today and
tomorrow
that is really bringing together a group
of interdisciplinary and
multidisciplinary thought leaders to
help advance the conversation around the
areas of ethics and AI the ways in which
technologies especially computational
technologies are able to help us support
and advance human values and one a
really important part of this
conversation is is the distinguished
keynote lecture that we have this
evening which is really I think going to
be a highlight of the conference and
introduce the speaker it is my honor to
bring to the podium mr. Mike cassis who
is the chairman of the management
committee of the law firm K&L Gates as
well as a world leader in investment
management and regulatory compliance
Mike
[Applause]
thank you very much and it's a pleasure
being here and I have to tell you it is
an honor to introduce dr. Eric Horvitz
when you think of the purpose of this
inaugural lecture to talk about current
trends future trends challenges and
opportunities in ethics and artificial
intelligence you couldn't think of a
better person to do it than Eric eric
has been active in addressing many of
these issues for over 30 years he's
currently the director of Microsoft
research labs and and at Microsoft as a
technical fellow and in Redmond
Washington as I mentioned his whole
career has focused on that he has been
has this unique skill that in this area
where can be so technical and very
difficult in order to take all the
various issues that are being faced in
order to describe it in well I would say
in layman's terms he has his excellent
skill to take these concepts and let the
average person understand the
opportunities the challenges the
benefits he has worked on safety issues
in the Space Shuttle but also at the
same time he has done fantastic work and
AE dealing with email systems and
scheduling systems so every day how
every day lives have been changed by
some of the work he has done you know
Eric he's really a double doctor not
only does he have PhD he also has an MD
so a lot of his work has been done
focusing in the medical field one of his
challenges has been and worried always
has been is as doctors in under
stressful conditions and emergency rooms
and other situations get a lot of data
how do they analyze that and help the
patient understand that that some of the
efforts that Eric has focused on his he
did his dissertation 25 years ago
talking
about these issues and his first
publication was on Pathfinder which was
a tool to help internships in order to
in the diagnostic area in order to
simplify information they receive to
help them make better decisions he has
been an elite recently he's been a
leader to examine the many difficult
ethical social and psychological
questions raised by advancement in AI in
2009 while he was apprentice the
president of the Association of
advancement artificial intelligence
commonly referred to as triple AI he
also chaired the groundbreaking a
similar AI study which brought together
blue-ribbon group many of those people
are in this room to identify examine the
potential human social impacts of AI
research and development the study of
self accept has helped set the agenda
for many the topics at this session here
at this past day and and tomorrow he
profound at the 100 year study on AI to
anticipate the diverse effects of
artificial intelligence on every aspect
of our lives in the coming century that
is writing eric is not a doomsayer he's
not a futurist he's a very practical
person taking all the different aspects
of this burgeoning area in that and
using it to reshape our lives and also
use the challenges and opportunities to
help society in a AI area he is Eric has
received numerous rewards he's a fellow
the National Academy of Engineering the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
the American College of medical
informatics the triple AI as I mentioned
and the Association for Computing
Machinery or common referred to as ACM
he has buys government agencies
foundations major research institutions
and is testified in front of the US
Congress in 2015 he received both the
Triple A I died
prize for outstanding artificial
intelligence research and real-world
domains and also the AIC M triple a I
new award named for CMU zone Allen Neuer
for its contribution to artificial
intelligence and human-computer
interaction integration which integrated
both computing and decision sciences he
has developed some of the core methods
and systems advanced understanding of
machine intelligence and works to
harmonize these advances to improve our
everyday lives as technology is
spreading in all aspects of our lives
communities and societies Eric has
always been a leader in this area again
he's very practical he balances the
pluses and the minuses and he turns them
into areas that will improve up day to
day life I'm honored to have him we are
all honored to have him deliver this
neural lecture at the K announced
distinguished lecture series Eric
welcome thank you very much
well if I ever need a campaign director
political office I've know where to look
so I thought I'd go back a bit to why
I'm so excited about AI in open world it
all started with my reading as an
undergraduate of herb Symons writings
about how people in AI artifacts are
relatively simple systems emerged
immersed in large complex environments
and therefore we must contend with
inescapable uncertainties in
incompleteness and this raised lots of
questions for me that I took into my
graduate work about what were technical
paths forward in this world going from a
lab environment into the open world what
would that take in the future in
building medical systems that work just
fine in the lab what happened in the
hospital and in the doctor's office and
in sorry to field technologies and
watching them work with people and
people work with them this other
interesting challenge or set of
challenge problems came to the fore on
societal influences and practices and
policies the open world AI problem that
was a much broader one that I had been
used to now when I took on the trip the
presidency of the triple AI the the
larger society of AI scientists in the
world
I made the theme of my presidency AI in
the open world and as part of that
although most of my talk and I was a
slide from that lecture that I gave the
presidential lecture that presidents
gave at Triple A I focused mostly on
technical issues that's really exciting
questions you have to ask about what's
the system helping you get systems
self-knowledge that it doesn't know
everything
that it has blind spots when it works in
the world and learns to become better
for example or knows what to ask people
for help I also asked and made a
commitment that I would bring together
some great computer scientists probably
the first time we assembled AI research
scientists to ask questions about
long-term AI features at the
intersection of AI people and society
now the front page of the New York Times
reported this about the meeting that we
had after several months of breakout
groups and so on but while these topics
were touched upon the future of machines
that might become smarter than us and
and and and not let us intervene we
mostly focused on short-term disruptions
and possibilities ethics challenges and
legal challenges and questions and it
was a very rich set of findings
now that was February of 2009 and in
July of 2009 at Microsoft Research geoff
hinton and two graduate students
visiting us started looking at neural
net systems of the form that Geoff had
been looking at all along but had come
into disfavor given that they didn't
work as well as some of the traditional
machine learning methods but we
discovered that summer that these
methods were simply famished for data
all those years and when we fed them
data all of a sudden we had speech
recognition that actually worked I
shouldn't say that that way cuz Roger
Eddy's in the audience but worked well
to the level of human Trent professional
transcriptionist today same methods
applied to the image object recognition
and image classification gave us object
recognition recently at for the data set
that's being looked at human level as
well as reading challenges and other
challenges using the same basic set of
methods that are really being fed with
incredible quantities of data and beyond
simple wedges we're beginning to
assemble pipelines that involve several
different kinds of methods natural
language analyses combined with vision
to give us automated captioning systems
like you see here and the R&D continues
now with recognizing behaviors from
video for example now these interesting
new developments have been pressed very
quickly into service by the big
companies and by in academia and by
people that the maker community for
example described translator now
translates between languages speech to
speech in a methodology that just a few
years ago had us at the edge of our
seats with prototypes that barely worked
and there are widely available tools now
the
to be used and programmed with by almost
anybody that give us the power in
software to see faces recognize gender
and emotion and so on now that said the
reason I'm so excited about this field
these days even beyond some of the the
foundations of intelligence and the
questions there which I should say to be
honest most of which remain unanswered
which makes it very exciting the
opportunities to have big influence in
the world are huge so this shows you
this readmissions predictor we built
several years ago and shipped around the
world for Microsoft Research at the time
we knew that 20% of Medicare reimbursed
patients were bouncing back to hospitals
within a month and the estimates for the
costs of preventable readmissions were
20 billion dollars in the US alone why
wouldn't we want to build a system that
could learn to predict which patients at
discharge time are going to bounce back
to give him special care monitoring and
packages that would keep them healthier
this brings up this issue about ethics I
believe we have a ethical imperative to
apply AI to the best that we can to save
lives and to raise the quality of life
where we can several years ago just a
few years ago the British Medical
Journal estimated and this confirmed
other studies that the third most common
cause of death in the United States is
preventable error in hospitals right
after heart disease in cancer it's like
a city the size of Oakland quietly
disappearing every year or Miami without
any front page news about it powerful
she asked the question could a I systems
augment or extend human intelligence to
be like the the safety net under the
bridge workers catching errors when they
could happen now here's an example of
work like that just give you a sense
before we head into the rough edges of
AI thought we should start by talking
about the upside
this is a model that we built working
with this is emotion by arty and mark
Braverman two postdocs at Microsoft and
Jason Gatewood an emergency room
physician at a large urban hospital
using 20 years of data and here's the
nice nature of the training set for an
emergency room department Andy look at
all patients that were discharged and
came back within 48 hours to the
hospital within two days were admitted
to the hospital
with a significant problem as an
inpatient and the primary diagnosis was
nowhere on the chart
when they were discharged from the
emergency room I would call that an
expert human surprise something that
support would surprise most you know
yesterday this was something was hiding
in the cognitive shadows for example of
the expert so when this model runs it's
not replicating what the human knows
it's thinking about what the human
doesn't know what's at the frontier of
its experts knowledge and when it says
hey before you let this patient go this
might surprise you do you want to see
what I'm thinking a physician might
listen carefully and this work has led
to richer work right now this is where
the student daily on a problem called
failure to rescue in hospitals that's a
really scary phrase which means death
happened in the hospital after a
treatable complication
set in which then led to a cascade
typically an organ system cascade on to
death now these two examples are
examples we're talking about AI designs
for complementarity where we reason
explicitly about the blind spots and
biases and gaps that people have in
their cognition and think about
explicitly how does machine intellect
work with people work with cognitive
psychology machine learning and planning
to extend our abilities designing for
complementarity many AI advances will be
applied in this way and make the world
better for it now that said just in like
if you think about just in three weeks
or so or four weeks these are actual
headlines
talking about the rough edges that we're
facing and critical problems with
advances in this field so here we have
on one hand their incredible promise
which I which is which is energizing and
exciting but we have to get this other
side right and do our best with it it's
critical so the way I like to abstract
some of these problems in my mind are in
terms of capabilities can we reason
about and work with the blind spots and
biases in our algorithms
they'll probably always be there how can
we work with them and minimize their
impact and their existence values what
are the utilities the values represented
in reasoning systems when they do
cost-benefit analyses and with the word
agency in the decision analysis field
we often say for a decision who's the
principal agent of that decision which
means who's whose resources and life is
at stake
who is making the decision a doctor
might be helping a patient but the
patient is the principle agent and then
misuse this is a very very rich and
intriguing area and this is we're gonna
require attention human rights
possibility by elections legal ethical
and privacy challenges physical and
emotional harms exclusion from
consequential services manipulation of
attention through capture engagement and
persuasion one thing we don't think
about a lot which actually I was happy
to hear came up this morning in the
first session is that and I asked myself
why early on in my career didn't I think
about the the rich deep societal
challenges and rough edges and it was
because we were building one-off systems
maybe we could sell a few at a startup
we could talk to the people who were
crazy enough to buy these crazy systems
and tell them how to use it and fill
them in on the down
and upsides but now we mean this is
often unstated we're in a world because
of how much the world change because of
the web and the connectivity it brought
of ease of replicating reusing anything
that we build at internet scale which
means that nuances in a single solution
will call a single solution Facebook
it's a single app have wide and deep
societal influences so in the back of my
mind I'm always thinking this when I
think about AI right it's like in the
back of my mind it means like we build
something and it could have big effects
worldwide that said let me just walk
through some of these issues and how I
think about them and maybe we can Mabel
get to do some Q&A on this as well on
capability is entrust loud C was said to
have said the translation knowing that
you do not know is the best and the
translation goes not knowing that you do
not know is an illness can we give our
systems the ability to know and not know
so at the risk of sounding like Donald
Rumsfeld in there there are now systems
that are making life-and-death decisions
and you're seeing recent deaths about
perform about the physical world based
on perceptual streams so this is the
view I have in my Tesla I couldn't
resist buying one of these when that
came out given the fact that I was gonna
do self do it self-driving someday in
quotes from the salesperson and indeed
software came down and I started doing
automated driving with the autopilot
feature so when I'm driving along and
you might hear in an autopilot you see a
little view of the car and what the car
seeing the senses are seeing and at some
point in time the car might lose
confidence and what you see it you hear
an alarm will sound and you get a
message like this auto steer is no
longer steering model as confidently
take over and the car throws back
control to you no matter what your
you grab the wheel you know and this is
called unknown unknown because we we we
trust that the car has a well calibrated
model of confidence and when it doesn't
know something now think about the the
challenge of designing a car to be
self-driving do the people up the Tesla
factory or Ford or at Toyota really have
the ability to go through all
possibilities this one got me one night
late night zooming along on the highway
I saw cones in the distance while an
auto pilot and I wondered does the Tesla
know about cones that you know they'd
sweep across the road and close a lane I
waited and waited and then I said hands
on the wheel it's not gonna know it's
gonna hit him head-on but I had no
knowledge about what the car didn't know
this is another example people know
Genet wing and xt Wang they're of two
lungs from CMU they were driving with me
to an exec retreat when we in autopilot
when we encountered this scene and it
wasn't clear to me that the Tesla
designer has had this in mind we think
the system had a lot of pilot so this is
the challenge of unknown unknowns and
it's a real challenge we call these
blind spots now in the technical work we
can actually even use deep neural nets
to learn to focus them on the problem of
learning to predict confidence in how a
base level system will work and then
there's new work on my team and other
teams coming about which are ways to
triage human engineering attention to
find blind spots to identify unknown
unknowns in the open world this is early
research but it's critical and even in
reinforcement learning and in this paper
here how do you discover blind spots in
a system that learned its whole life how
to live and do its thing in a simulator
now put in the real world where it
should it be scared about where should
it be a little bit nervous or anxious
but beyond the technology and I think
that it's very good research and I'm
sure like I see great research coming
out of the CMU departments which have
been leading
I can I can now say what the number one
department in the country per US News &
World Report
round of applause I would actually say
look US News World News apart I'd say
well deserved
but beyond technology there's the idea
of practices and designs so why not what
is the policy at which we we defer the
fielding of technology we say it's not
ready maybe for trials but it's not
ready to be used by by the popular
populations or do we need to have phased
trial like the FDA clinical trial phase
one phase two and post marketing
surveillance required study and
standards of reporting during these
times so we know what's going on but say
we want to feel technology how do we
disclose the nature of the behavior the
risks and the failure modes and there's
a whole field outside of AI and in many
cases outside of computer science called
failsafe design like air brakes on
trains invented in Pittsburgh actually
at a used worldwide one of the first
examples of failsafe designs where if
anything goes wrong the system stops we
can fold designs but with blind spots
that we can't get rid of potentially
with new kinds of engineering practices
this area of bias and fairness is
getting quite a bit of attention and
it's important one the article by by
Julia Angwin and and co-authors focused
on this idea that or the reality that
there was a system called compass being
used throughout the country to help
judges make decisions on bail and on
holding a person charged with a crime
versus letting them go before their
court date thinking about whether they
commit a violent crime in the mean time
and the article about the challenges
that were discovered some of the
challenges and they're still being
investigated because it's not all
straightforward that here's two cases
that you know sort of were analyzed by
the data and some of the risk reports
that that came up now it's
just the the high-profile cases that
have these problems its prolific so at
Microsoft and a Howard a roboticist
visited with me for a year year and a
half ago and we looked at some of
Microsoft's cognitive services and this
is a cognitive service as we call them
these are services available on the
Azure web available for use in
programming for a motion detection and
we discovered that the emotion pacifier
it's not as charged as race but the
emotion classifier had certain failure
modes for children and we went and
looked and studied the data set we had
to find it and who did the data set and
oh yes it didn't have a lot of children
and it it was and therefore it was it
was biased and that is the performance
didn't work as well in some areas and
this is the two who other studies like
this blitz a large-scale efforts inside
Microsoft and more in that in a few
minutes to come up with ways to detect
and address biases and our services
values and agency let me just show you a
curve here this curve up on though on
the screen here isn't the typical kind
of performance curve that computer
scientists look at when they build a
pattern recognizer or machine learn
classifier from data and they typically
hold out a little bit of data usually
the most recent data they let's say in a
medical case because the most recent
data it looks like the data most looks
like the data you'll see in the world so
they hold that out from the training and
they say we're going to test our system
with this holdout set that the the
learning algorithm has not seen before
and then you generate one of these
curves and what you see on there is a
true positive and a false positive rate
so it tells us for example and this is
actually the the one of the receiver
operator characteristic curves as
they're called one of the curves from
the readmissions prediction work we done
and one of the early curves in our
research from about 15 years of medical
data of readmissions to a hospital
within 30 days so this the idea was we
want to predict when patients will
return to the hospital within a month
it's actually tracked by Medicare to
penalize able
quality measure and it says here that if
you operated this threshold here we can
tell that the classify will tell you you
know if it says patients going to come
back three quarters of the time it will
be correct but the false positive rate
will be twenty five percent they won't
come back and you can imagine moving
this threshold around and having what
are called different operating
characteristics or operating ranges for
this classifier well it turns out if you
think about what does it mean for a true
positive and a false positive it means
something very different for your spam
filter right then for a patient and for
a cardiac patient for example this gets
at the idea of costs and benefits and
depending on where I picked that
threshold really affects the performance
of the system in a way that affects the
end users costs and benefits that they
receive and this includes significant
health implications now looking at this
more broadly the golden go back here
most machine learning research takes
data sets and gives you probability
distributions about what you care about
like a prediction
what disease does the patient have
what's the wind flow going to be over a
over a city United States from wind
sensors what a motion if somebody have
on their face right now and we need to
do more of the full decision analysis to
cause decision-making based on the
predictive model is where the rubber
meets the road and so I call this
they're kind of like the golden data to
predictions the decisions pipeline and
this is where we really get into value
and it's not just automation it's Vic
for recommendation engines as well to
off to a young doctor for example
looking at the output of one of these
systems now think about the decision
model the decision model takes in a set
of probabilities and based on a
cost-benefit consideration outputs the
ideal action to take and that depends on
the details in a decision model which
captured
the value or the utility structure in
the person being affected that's the
intention the principal agent of
decision now we discovered when we
shipped our readmission system that a
large hospital system in the Midwest of
the United States was playing with
thresholds and they said when the
Microsoft score it's actually a
probability but they called it a
Microsoft score is greater than 25 they
will initiate a special package for a
patient which costs quite a bit of money
but they'll initiate it they'll take
that charge and it turns out by doing
that they saved 1.4 million dollars per
year and they're in the hospital we sat
down and did a real a rich decision
analysis with many costs and benefits
and and and and look this up and so on
and showed that the actual details were
quite nuanced and it really depended on
careful modeling of the utility function
so you can't just ship a classifier and
have it be used in the world and expect
it to do the right thing for everybody
because how health you know different
attributes of what you care about in a
health outcome go into the utility
structure here so you have to ask in any
a I system whose utility function what
cost benefit analysis who assessed it
who refined it who inspected it could we
reveal it to disclose it to now on
misuses it's as we all know it's quite
possible to use these technologies to
empower and amplify the the tyranny of
leaders who don't have the best don't
have the best in mind for their populace
freedom of association freedom of
expression new kinds of surveillance in
policing but also a misuse commitment
can be included to include the risk of
deaths that they're serious injury in a
system that's us failing too much to be
shipped or a system that's unfair and
it's denying consequential services and
resources to people or a system that's
manipulating the attention beliefs
voting patterns and cognition of people
let me talk about that last notion right
now because it's been on my mind quite a
bit lately and I'm so much in a few
minutes we have a working group of
Microsoft right now looking at this very
carefully the idea of using the of the
best minds coming out of our grad school
departments in machine learning going
off to work at companies that are
harnessing their talents to optimize
what your attention is focused on how
much time are you spending on an
application so if you look at this pie
chart here all the things you attend to
during the day we know now that
large-scale data analysis and planning
and personalized policies are being used
to make to maximize your attention and
time on applications and this is in
accordance with optimizing the dollars
back to the people writing those
algorithms now back to her appointment's
again herb Simon talked about a poverty
of human attention coming in a world
full of information and distraction it's
an important concept to think about what
this is doing to our daily lives
I like Tori to use the less polite
phrase that these are adversarial
attacks on human attention for someone
else has gained whether it be
shareholders or owners of a company so
thinking forward on where we're going in
the world with this and we're what our
kids will be immersed in and our
grandkids we have to think deeply about
preferences on time well spent
long-term preferences on what we want to
be doing with our time and thinking
deeply about policies disclosure
shouldn't I be told that there's an
algorithm focused on my mind that
maximizes the time of engagement I will
spend in this application controls in
education
perhaps as interesting and intriguing
and concerning is AI manipulation you
know we have people even here at CMU
study marketing it's a great concept and
topic and people have long studied
propaganda they're experts at that the
different words and there are different
intentions but the idea of turning away
from back-of-the-envelope theories and
sketches to large-scale data centric
manipulation is concerning so work by
Seymour and Tully a couple years ago
that I was talking about a few years ago
when this first came up it took a large
number of Twitter feeds including geotag
Twitter's Twitter feeds where is
somebody right now what are they doing
and so on
what are they tweeted about in the past
and showed how you can build very
personalized tweets in this case tweets
being written by a neural network that
would maximally have a maximal
probability of a user clicking on a link
and even created toolkits you can now
download and use to build your own Robo
tweeter we've heard a lot about
Cambridge analytical recently and
Facebook data well a few years ago when
I made this slide before we had such
noteworthy news I was talking about the
concerns in less academic paper by
Kaczynski at L that showed from just
Facebook data from a little bit of
training data I'm not sure what little
bit was by the way but but here the
inferences that are being made from just
a facebook scan of your Facebook of feed
are you single on orally or in
relationship are your parents together a
twenty one Christianity versus Islam gay
lesbian or straight uses drugs and
alcohol satisfied with life that's
interesting
emotional stability age gender and so on
so there's clearly going to be need for
some reflection and guidance in all
those areas that I mentioned today the
capabilities and had a handle blind
spots and biases the values and the idea
of principle agency and the this whole
area of the the potential harms that
might come with use of these systems to
human rights and related areas so I see
that there's a continuing a need for I
would say continuing processes like the
endowment that came to CMU for this
program for study and productivity we
need to fund these kinds of programs and
centers there are roles for industry for
the academy for civil society and
government five years ago or so my wife
and I came up with a crazy idea and this
was at the kind of the five-year point
after the Asilomar study the triple AI
study and we looked at the report we
said so many interesting questions came
up and so many were so prescient in
terms of what was being said about what
we needed to care about two or three
things were like just dead on maybe we
were lucky but they were very
interesting and if we had followed some
of the guidance we would have been
further ahead we thought let's do
another study plus five years but it
really was clear to me this would have
to happen plus five years several times
and so we thought why don't we endow
Stanford with with it with the study and
John Hennessy at the time thought this
was a great idea even though the
Development Office what we were crazy
but every five years forever have a
standing committee that that works with
a with a study committee that does a
study that does that same that proactive
advice for governments academia the
public at large civil society on
problems coming to the fore and the
first report was published about a year
and a half ago
what about corporate accountability that
was kind of philanthropic and academic
I've been doing a lot of reading lately
of Peter Drucker's work who knows who
Peter Drucker was in this room
all these Heinz people are here and
others so Peter Drucker I think this
defines some some of the 20th century
deep thinking about business practices I
think his whole he came up with the
whole idea of an MBA being even a field
he said that profit is not the primary
goal only in a central condition for
sustainability and that a company's
primary primary primary responsibility
is to service customers here's a quote
leaders in every single institution and
in every sector not just business are
responsible also for the community as a
whole we're not in it just to maximize
shareholder value that said I've been
impressed that I want to be to an
advertisement for Microsoft here but
I've been impressed with the the
responsiveness of the company to
concerns about the long term futures and
even short term needs and and rough
edges with with AI systems and we set up
about two years ago the ether committee
it stands loosely for AI and ethics in
engineering and research there are seven
working groups it's been an intensive
effort touching on every issue that I
mentioned today and I should say that
I'm happy to say that this committee has
teeth so when it came to so some of them
so mentioned humanitarian issues and
some questions have come up about can't
what could a company do when it comes to
technologies being used that put it at
risk for human rights commitments and I
should say that the the ether committee
has has made recommendations which have
gone all the way up to the senior
leadership and
significant sales have been cut off and
in other sales very explicit limitations
were written down in a terms of usage
including may not use data-driven
pattern recognition for use in face
recognition or predictions of this type
so if committee has working groups and
we refer to the guiding principles on
business and human rights and Microsoft
has its own global global human rights
statement we take very seriously and
that we see going right up to the top of
the company if we say we see a challenge
we point at this document and we and we
say this is a risk to our commitment
selling this technology to this customer
moving to the community at larger
community I want to talk a little about
the the before I finish up here the the
partnership on AI which was a consortium
set up about started about three years
ago it started by with leadership by the
research leads at the research
laboratories at amazon google deepmind
Microsoft Facebook and IBM we all know
each other as colleagues and when it
came to discussions at conferences we
said I wonder if we can drag our
companies whether they're kicking us
kicking and screaming or they're happy
with all this into a consortium to a
nonprofit focused on best practices
across a set of interesting questions
and challenge areas in at the
intersection of AI people on society
including safety critical systems
fairness accountable and transparent
algorithms human AI collaboration labor
AI labor in the economy deeper social
and societal influences and we're
talking about some of the issues I
talked about with persuasion and
manipulation and so on and it's a
balance it led by a balanced board
including folks representing the ACLU
nonprofit AI research
foundations economists privacy experts
nai scientists recently we brought on
Tara Lyons to be the executive director
and she's doing a great job getting this
operation up into the air so moving
ahead I see the direction we need to
pursue includes ongoing research on the
principles the foundations they're so
exciting and we need to better
understand human intelligence and its
computational variants we need to work
to apply anything that we know and have
learned to key societal challenge
problems we need to continue to identify
and address costs and influences of the
technologies and ethical and human
rights challenges and I say that we need
to collaborate widely on the
technologies and their influence on
society in a multi-party stakeholder
approach including economists public
policy people psychologists and so on
and let me just end back to her
assignment again and I want to basically
set the bar lower for us I think I think
what we're facing some very tough
problems and I want to just talk about
satisficing one of herbes words and he
said that professional responsibility is
not to discover the laws of the universe
but to act responsibly in the world by
transforming existing situations into
more preferred ones I'll stop there
Thanks
[Applause]
thank you so much it's a really
wonderful talk and I think fit all of
the themes I think every single one of
the session themes over the course of it
I tried I wanted to start by asking
about actually a theme that has been a
part of your research since the
beginning which is this idea that we
need to fit nicely with features human
cognitive biases and so in particular
there are now many calls for AI to be
more transparent or explainable could
you say a bit about what you think is
needed for AI beyond just accuracy or
simple performance measures like that so
there are many applications of AI
including many applications that you
might say are running under the hood so
Windows 10 for example has machine
learning running all the time in a
private way under the hood guessing what
you'll do next and and then prefetching
and pre-loading so everything's faster
magically if it's done well and I think
it is it's been running for for a number
of years and different versions since
Windows 7 we don't ask for transparency
on that unless you have a special
request as to what's going on exactly
want it to be very efficient in human
facing technologies like dialogue
systems we want to have we might want to
have other features of you know human
more human-like comfortable with humans
new music don't are not weirded out by
the technology assurance about of
privacy you know when it comes to
transparency it's interesting question I
think that it's gonna vary depending on
usage I see some day us wanting to make
sure that some independent party that we
trust as a proxy has certified for
example the data sets that were used the
the processes in place that that systems
are fair and unbiased person protected
variables for example but the best ovens
were used on underwear as laboratory or
or or or at FDA
somebody's looking at this
as best practice and relieves me a bit
of the need to go inspecting and why
don't you know all about what's going on
in the case I think we need to sort of
think through a system working with an
expert how to best explain inferences
how to do sensitivity analysis do
something called counterfactuals
what would have happened if this patient
didn't have that black mole but still
had this other dermatological do
visualizations we found in that work
that I showed you that showing this this
2d visualization of how utility how cost
and benefit interacted under uncertainty
for a population was very useful in in
understanding policy at a hospital I
think we can't look at AI as one thing a
high-level comment here it's an
interesting phrase I think artificial is
actually an unfortunate I wish it was
called computational intelligence it's
artificial scares people I think that
the word but it's a it's it refers to a
large set of related disciplines or
radon understanding the kinds of things
that people can do with ease from a
computational lens and there's many
things it's a it's a it's a wipe it's a
it's an empty canvas with lots of pink
and looking to many things with it
and each of those points in that space
will have different requirements in
terms of how best to to adapt to human
beings how best to to extend or
constrain the system in a variety in
ways that make it more usable acceptable
for human human interaction well this
idea that that the AI we have to think
not just about the AI but what it's for
so it's AI for a purpose for a goal
whether that's you know defined in a
loss function or some other way I guess
that raises a question because of course
diverse people can have Traverse goals
that might even come into conflict with
one another so is that something that
you think falls to the developer does
that fall to the user to figure out what
the goals are should we allow the AI to
try and learn
goals are or is that a fraud project
well let's just talk about what's
shipping today we're talking about
relatively fixed technologies that
recognize patterns and do very
relatively simple things so when we
build those systems we want to annotate
them very carefully including how we
test performance with which is like this
system was built from this kind of data
its intended purpose was to detect age
or gender or the emotional status of
someone's facial features this system
performs this well how do we know that
here is the representative test that we
used to even understand this performance
which captures an intended purpose now
you can imagine weaving that inference
into another system that's using it in
some way that still understands the
intended purpose now in the future in a
future World Wars training systems in
the in the wild to learn general things
about life which doesn't exist now you
can imagine also to mention questions
coming to the fore about does the system
that was trained at the factory to this
level and then trained at my home to
with more data to personalize it does it
perform well when you know my husband or
a wife uses a system or my kid interacts
with it
and I think these are big research
questions that we wait you don't have
great answers for right now a theme that
ran through a lot of what you were just
saying is about the importance of a
certain kind of technical literacy
technological literacy that is perhaps
lacking in a lot of the public and a lot
of even policy and decision makers in
terms of being able to understand the
role of training data or how to go from
it was trained for this purpose
therefore it probably shouldn't be used
for this other one right question to ask
ourselves you know it's probably gonna
be hard to assume we can train people to
understand the details of a goes on with
these systems but you would hope for
example someday for example when it
comes to what
and car will do in one of these famous
settings or a nuanced situation that
rather than then being concerned with
what the auto manufacturer had to say
about this the car is not drivable in
automated mode until there is clear
signals at the end user watch the
material to learn about what these
trade-offs are and then went ahead after
even taking an exam or test and and
assessed preferences so it's the drivers
knowledge in the system when that carbon
was forward or the drivers preferences
about behavior and you can imagine
modularizing
operations in a certain way where yes I
feel comfortable that I could actually
explain to an end-user even without much
computer science education what's gonna
happen in the setting visually and help
visualize and with the sets of controls
get at end-user assessments directly so
again it's up to computer scientists and
engineers and manufacturers and
salespeople to make sure that these
systems these more sophisticated systems
than we sold in the past are well
understood by the end-user and by the
way this end also includes maintenance
we never really thought about you know
what it takes to maintain a system in a
dynamic world once you ship it when we
shipped I'll save this out of 11 for
know this when we ship that medical
system that remission system years ago
it worked really well we trained it on
and tested in many hospitals what it did
was it trained in tests locally because
we found that the data set from one
hospital didn't do well to generalize to
another hospital it was fine right
before we shipped it I said wait a
minute maintenance we didn't think about
these issues in those days it's a
standalone package that runs with data
locally I said can you um have that
system whenever a tree trains anywhere
in the world send email to me with that
curve and you know but nowadays at
Microsoft we say what are the terms of
reference and the terms of usage
including required maintenance and
chickens by end-users
stand that the world moves around miss
dynamic and you have to really keep keep
maintaining these systems make sure they
perform well well of course when we
think about local learning there's a
rather notorious case where local
learning went poorly and that was the
chat box
Tay so how do we balance ensuring that
the local learning occurs in an
unsupervised way there's the human
they're necessarily looking over the
shoulder anymore but that it learns the
runt for achieving the goal that the
developer and the end user had in mind I
was going to comment on teh sorry in
that it's a great example of things
going awry but it wasn't a very deep AI
system at all and it's attacked by
malevolent attackers but that doesn't
mean it's not a great example to think
deeply about what might happen in the
future you know you can imagine giving
systems the ability to monitor their
performance there's lots of chatter
about what does it mean to to add a
layer of reflection in systems where the
the meta level reasoner is simpler and
it looks out for certain problems it's
not very complicated and it's there as
kind of a century to to make sure that
the what's going on at the base level
the complicated system trying to learn
about the world is not getting off the
rails
and reports out and actually monitors
what's happening so you can imagine we
get as we build more reliable software
we build into them besides having people
maintain them and oversee them in
certain situations give them the give
them the ability to have a layer of of
an overview or a meta view of what's
going on at the base level so they can
start to recognize that there's some
unknown unknown out there they may not
right of course and and in fact there's
some really fabulous work by Tom
Dietrich over at Oregon State right now
on systems that actually learn when
there's a another class out there in
this case he did it for biology but that
the system didn't know about and there
are certain signatures that will show up
if there's something you just don't know
in the world that that's doing its thing
and you have it's the the blind spot has
a signature and so you can imagine that
kind of method as well
I do think that the nature and the
sophistication of our technologies will
be morphing over time and that rather
than saying we have solved this problem
we need to have these continuing studies
like the 100 year study like the ethics
and AI program we have here now like the
new block program and so in box Center
here I think they're all gonna be
required over time these these
challenges and opportunities I say
aren't going to go away and we'll have
solutions that will cascade and be
layered and we'll build on them but I
think we need to stay on it basically
because of technical but because the
advances can change our best controls
meta-reasoning understandings d biasing
techniques as we go and of course those
same things then interact back on the
human biases so you think about things
like the people's loss of awareness when
they go on autopilot
so the Tesla takes over for you and you
know to look at the the orange cones and
be ready to take over but we also know
from you know aviation studies that it's
very hard to be able to take over as I'm
sure you've also had that experience yet
the the whole issue of and the
importance of social and cognitive
psychology in understanding the human AI
relationship and in human at
collaboration and interaction more
generally is is is is deep and broad
it's great that CMU has fabulous
expertise in in both Yuma computer
interaction and AI and now these these
ideas are coming together in a variety
of places but but here as well and just
you thinking about I have some really
great pieces of video that show
prototype surgeons working
sorry prototype of robotic surgeons
working with human surgeons hand in hand
very quickly and you can imagine that if
you had a robotic surgeon working with a
human surgeon you see you see literally
four hands words or you know with three
hands in
in a scene and this signaling going on
is who's doing what
whose turn is it the idea of a mix of
initiatives are back and forth how does
that work how do we do it in a fluid
manner we're sitting here chatting in a
fluid manner you're doing predictions
about what I'm gonna end the sentence
and someone went to start
who's making contributions there's a
whole rich literature in psychology for
mutual grounding and conversation that
we think it's going to be important for
any human AI interaction when it comes
to interactive AI and fluid
collaboration well and also making sure
that the the AIS are able to as it were
augmented humans rather than simply
replace them which I think connects with
a lot of the the workforce issues that
get raised about the development of AI
technologies right is how can we have
the a I helped the human rather than
simply replace the human thereby leaving
them out of the workforce what person
will think that we ever want to
constrain the advantage of technology to
say we don't build systems that replace
people you know people used to drive
cars around and adjust the dwell angle
of their spark gap of their sparks on
their debt on their steering column I
don't know who remembers that but you
know in now sorry and now we have
automatic dwell advanced for those of
you car people out there so some jobs
you know or tasks we think will be
automated and I'll shift the nature of
the human task we hear about who's the
radiologist I said I'm gonna go away so
you know as you know radiology is not
necessarily about only recognizing
patterns and features on on a film it's
about helping the ordering physician
with the plan the the the rule out the
strategy what tests will look the best
it just will essentially shift the
nature of the job and what's learned to
be an expert radiologists
and the solution to a certain sub task
in radiology plus the human might be
create a very different more powerful
position in the future funny ways for
the human and machine to team together
team to advance far beyond what either
could do right but there's certainly
certainly the automation of the form
that that
that you know ameliorates the need to
have a human being on staff Ron on hand
now one thing we were discussing
actually this brings up but earlier
today at lunch was whether autumn the
rise of automation in the world I'll
just be toes that's the audience whether
the rise of automation will will help to
pressure the economies into valuing
human touch and human contact more the
rise of a caring the economy as some of
the things we rely on people now become
automated if there really is more wealth
created by this automation won't we
actually want to value human experience
human beings more someday and you know
teachers and mentors and elder care
providers are the top paid human being
is because they do the job the best I
think educators absolutely should be the
type of aid it's a wonderful idea and I
think on that on that wonderful right
thank you so much okay thank you
[Applause]